yeah well one of the things I really
can't figure out maybe you could shed
some light on this too is that you know
of all the things that women's political
movements should be doing in the West is
demanding as far as I can tell that the
Western countries let us say led by
their male rulers stop treating the
Saudis like art they're our allies and I
cannot understand why there hasn't been
concerted pressure put on Western
governments by women who are concerned
at least in principle with the equality
and freedom of women around the world to
stop treating the Saudis like they're
our allies and so not enough that's
another thing that perplexes me entirely
and the cynical part of me thinks that
the feminists who are more or less hell
bent on the destruction of the Western
patriarchy adopt the attitude that the
enemy of my enemy is my friend and so
they're willing to put up with what the
Saudis do but I don't think that's a
sufficient explanation so like and I
mean you can view our culture so to
speak a little bit from from the outside
position because you have moved in as an
immigrant and and that gives you a
viewpoint that that it's much more
difficult for someone within it to share
and so like what do you see as as
driving the absence of pressure let's
say from women on governments in
relationship to these I would say
reprehensible dictatorships what's going
on so the feminists who are preoccupied
with Western country active with the
white man's patriarchy what I see is
that they have first of all that's all
that they're focused only they do not
talk about discuss raise the issue of
men of color and the patriarchy of men
of color of immigrants of the nations
and countries men in nations and
countries outside of the lenses remember
now these feminists have also bought
into the identity politics therefore
cultural relativism to a protocol to
multiculturalism and all these things
are bad for women bad pairing western
women and bad for all so if you believe
take multiculturalism for instance that
all cultures are equal and that one
person has one project the white
constitute have nothing to say about the
culture of Islam Allah
you know since its people then they
think they can't use the infusion of to
pressure our government to address the
Satria fear the outsourcing that if
black women and Muslim women and you
know women of color if they wanted to
get out of fashion then they should
organize themselves that's what they
believe what I find ironic draw is that
sometimes when we do organize ourselves
I am organized with other ex-muslim
women to talk about the misogyny that's
subjected to women in the name of Islam
white feminist atheist and that's really
the biggest puzzle ever I know well I
think that the treatment that you've
received at the hand of Western
feminists to me that's that something
that's just absolutely ah
it leaves me absolutely speechless
because you know not only me it's all of
us again like I only to X Muslims but
they're black women who are fights over
for their rights and they all get shut
down